les jeunes aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe ils passent le bac et ils vont
faire leurs études ailleurs ils ne
reviennent pas il faut absolument qu'on
puisse les conserver sur notre
territoire il faut qu'on offre une offre
de formations adéquates pour que nos
jeunes puissent rester sur le territoire
il ya des parents qui n'ont pas les
moyens d'envoyer leurs jeunes faire des
études ailleurs donc offrons des
possibilités pour que les jeunes restent
sur le territoire soient embauchés sur
le territoire et comme les entreprises
on le soulignait tout à l'heure
effectivement elle manque d'effectif
mais les entreprises ne peuvent pas
venir si effectivement elle n'ont pas le
personnel nécessaire dans notre ville
donc il faut d'abord qu'on forme notre
perdre les jeunes et les moins jeunes
peut se plier en ont besoin et
qu'ensuite on réponde aux entreprises et
les entreprises viendront parce qu'elles
auront un bassin d'emploi valable c'est
pas possible autrement